hey guys i'm ryan right so today i am
going to be doing yet again another 1up
box unboxing video I found out that
Tyrone Magnus does 1up box unboxing
videos as well well I'll have you know I
started mine first so Tyrone you're a
copycat you think because you're black
and you got a bigger [ __ ] to me that you
can just do that well that's
understandable anyway let's get to it no
more beating around the bush oh [ __ ] i
wish Tyrone was here to open this I
think this month's theme is sidekick
let's see oh damn oh boy oh yeah it's
adventure time but like kind of like a
Game Boy ooh this is fun this is cute I
have a collection of dolls i have a
pacman doll and a Pikachu doll this is
gonna go perfect with that all right
next item next item on the list it's
something it's a bag some type of bag
was the bag sag beep boop beep boop beep
boop it's oh dude I need a bag
constantly carrying around like all my
marijuana in this terrible bag but now I
got a great bag to carry on my weed my
coke my [ __ ] needles for my heroine
it's all in here now thanks 1up box I'm
glad I have a subscription to you I
can't but you made this bag impossible
to show that's pretty neat okay what
else is in here ooh I like this one I
just want to want I like it a lot Mon
Tucker beach very intense it's very
exciting footage for all you you watch
me try to unravel this present okay
there we go Oh sidekick game who better
than no Robin it's a dog tag of robbing
people it's a dog tag of the rob and the
back is a cape that cool love
and Nightwing's my favorite character
may not be Robin to Robin becomes in
case you guys didn't know that all right
let's see this is so hard to like go
through this bus feels like a wristband
my psychic heart my sidekick is what it
says I don't know if you guys can see it
but it's a heart and it says my sidekick
on it I'm gonna wear this because
Veronica's my sidekick or I'm her
sidekick let's face it she has more
balls than me all right let's look next
let's look next I love their stickers I
love there so I'm not gonna lie not sure
who this is I feel like an idiot for not
knowing but I have a dark Vader sticker
right here you guys can't see it it's
cut off right at the screen but now I
got a joker one this looks great now for
the big one the one I've been waiting
for and they sent it in the right size
this time here we go the shirt hmm no
way you got badass Yoshi over here dawg
oh yeah that's tight I like that a lot
[ __ ] shirts are my favorite thing I'm
always changing up my shirts now or I
recycle my shirts like the same like
five shirts I wear now this is my sixth
shirt okay yeah 1up box continues to do
it again I have a new shirt I got a new
bag that i could go grocery shopping
with or carry my drugs around with me i
get into your new doll and uh what else
I got the dog tag I got the dog tag
Robin I got the my sidekick wristband
and I got this cool sticker so yeah 1up
box do it it's only like 12 or 13 bucks
a month i don't know i don't check my
bank statements look at something around
that range and yeah yeah join the
goodies and you know what you guys get
on one of bucks I put a link in the
description box to go buy one if you
guys want one but if you guys get on one
of bucks [ __ ] instagram and tag me in
it that's at the real rejects ok do that
and if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where if
we get enough followers product
placement
you hear me one out box do you hear me
I'm talking about product placement when
I bucks private placement do we have a
deal there's one more thing oh it's a
one a box sidekick pin of Robin Oh Robin
is the most familiar psychic for sure
anyway guys thanks a lot the goodies
that I can get is because of you guys
sorry I don't share my goodies with you
but my way of sharing them is presenting
them to you to be like thank you now
because of you I get fun [ __ ] like this